welcome back to Las Vegas now tomorrow
is international Coffee Day and ronwyn
Decora from Founders coffee is here to
kind of give us a head start on the
celebration and I wanted to start with a
little fun fact sure because you just
blew my mind so she gave me a little
Founders coffee pin and I said oh is
that a goat on the pin I said it's
perfect for me because I'm a Capricorn
and then what did you tell me goats
found coffee we found coffee from goats
so go to eat some little coffee beans
and get crazy afterwards and we were
like hey what is that what's going on
with the goats
our mascot is a goat that's so cool and
also you know some education now that
we're celebrating we celebrated National
Coffee Day yesterday and now tomorrow is
international Coffee Day so what is
international Coffee Day mean it's the
whole world everybody's everybody's
celebrating coffee because coffee comes
from all over the world it does
absolutely you know and you have so many
beans from different regions at
different styles of coffee and that's
kind of what we know we like to offer in
our menu absolutely and you know I
figure this is a huge week for founders
with all of the these different coffee
days watching fall stuff and watching
fall toast fall drinks we just launched
a matcha menu so October's pretty
exciting yeah it's like Sweater Weather
and hot coffee weather it's all in one I
brought some ice options too thank you
okay because I might chug this one right
here that one was so good so let's
introduce the new fall flight yeah so
this is
a seasonal toast fight we always do
coffee flights we change it every month
so this is the first time doing a
seasonal toes fight which I did bring
here today and we do toast flights with
all of our other toasts on the menu but
our seasonal toast fight we have a
caramel apple pecan we have a bacon and
Brie with a fake jam and a banana
pumpkin crunch with a pumpkin pie cream
cheese that is not your basic toast no
it's wow that's sweet and savory that's
amazing but it's absolutely delicious
you can also mix these in with our other
toast fight if you want I love it a
toast fight is brilliant but also to
your other brilliant flight the coffee
place I actually had to launch it early
because people were so ready for fall
flavors so we've got a french toast
latte with a maple sugar rim okay which
one as you talk about which one should I
try
um
[Music]
I'm so sorry
you got it is it the pumpkin sugar try
so many coffees
this is the pumpkin company here with
the pumpkin whipped cream and espresso
we have a uh a brown sugar pecan and
then a brown sugar chai oh my gosh this
is so delicious the maple sugar is so
delicious this is so good tell everybody
how they can visit Founders where are
your two locations we are on St Rose
Parkway across from CostCo and then also
Sunset and Durango over by Ikea well
cheers to fall